we're in the archive of the Royal
Society in London and we've been doing
some quite serious research on papers
about iridium and osmium but now I want
to show you something that's not so
serious and really quite surprising so
come along with me it relates to the
famous physicist Ernest Rutherford who
was born in New Zealand and then moved
to via Canada to the UK and his famous
for smashing atoms and be one of the
pioneers of atomic structure and
although he was a physicist he won the
Nobel Prize for chemistry I think it's
always slightly irritated him we're used
to seeing Rutherford looking like this
as a famous old scientist or perhaps a
slightly younger scientist but already
famous now the object which I want to
show you I'm allowed to hold and it's
over here now it's made of wood and you
can see about a foot long 30 centimeters
long and looks as if it might be
something that I could hit you with and
this was made by Rutherford but it was
made by Rutherford and there's some
argument how old he was either around
the age of 10 or when he was a teenager
and it was made for his grandmother and
what this thing is is a potato masher
for making mashed potatoes you know that
some people don't like to eat their
potatoes whole and the idea is that you
bang the potato along like this and make
it mashed potatoes and I think that it's
really nice because it shows us that
even famous scientists were children
once we tend to remember them just when
they were really old I think that this
shows that not only was he and a famous
scientist and very inventive and
creative but even when he was right you
know he was trying to think of solutions
on how to solve practical problems how
to mash granny's potatoes I'm not sure
if the archive says whether she actually
used it
all just said thank you very much
earnest and put it away in the back of
her cupboard because she was embarrassed
that it was so useless however it looks
quite practical
it looks quite like a Maori weapon from
New Zealand so there may be a cultural
influence from his past here as well but
I'll leave that to some future historian
to deduce